is every artist a storyteller
every good artist is a storyteller yeah
so then people that are maybe more green
is that what's missing is the picture
isn't telling a story oh no
i think um sometimes green
artists are the best artists because
it's just like they tell a story they're
so they're not jaded by the industry and
they're just
telling a story and they saw something
beautiful and they think that it should
be on print or in
video format or something so they some
of the best things come out with
new artists and i those are the people i
try to complement the most when i see on
the internet because not the ones that
are published
they may not even get the message or
they may not receive it as much as like
someone from like i don't know
wyoming and they're like are you kidding
me thank you so much for
yeah i always i try to do that a lot um
green doesn't mean anything
i think that when it loses its
no i think green actually contributes
because you have the certain level of
just being naive
that you know makes you do gutsier
things
um i think what makes a bad picture is
when
you're trying to copy for the sake of
for the wrong intentions
for fame for insta fame
for endorsements
that's i think what makes it and it's
it's obvious
what do you think's tougher getting
started on youtube or instagram
yes um both of their own devils
i as a photographer or or for how for
whom
well that's a good point i mean because
what you do on youtube
is more sort of like how to for
photographers to make
money not just not just what their iso
and f-stop and all that but but how to
actually have a career from it
so building a following on youtube
versus instagram
this both seem like it's really tough
especially now
they're very tough um
so for my personal instagram i
gave up the number thing because i
rather have
quality versus quantity you know so a
brand
um i've lost some jobs because i didn't
have high enough followers
like you only have 8 000 where the
competing photographer
really it would matter for for being
hired for a job your social media
numbers
but they're realizing that those not all
of those photographers
can manage a set and put a vision
together and stay
um and stay under budget and you know
and
and put it all together right so they're
at that peak of
influencers and stuff as we knew it
yeah i lost many jobs i lost many jobs i
lost
a really big big big record cover
big record cover um to somebody
that that job was promised to me but
another photographer came
and said i will do it in a comparable
work
i will do it in exchange for instagram
tags
no no pay no pay and that's what you
mean about undercutting
undercutting that what they did what the
commissioner for the record label told
me was waleed what this person did
is not only hurt photographers because
she said to me
we just sit back and let you guys battle
it out
we don't do the work you guys destroy
each other she was very honest about it
because she also promised me the job
but she had a very hard time she was
like look
this is what i'm up against and i was
like i get it you know like it's a
business thing i get it i'm not happy
but i get it but she also told me that
this photographer
will not ever be able to get a good job
from them
because this i'm trying so hard to be
respectful this person's yeah
this photographer man i like um
sold themselves so cheap
that even if they ask for 500
we know we had them at an instagram tag
so they just destroyed themselves so
they can get some followers
and maybe get some bikini models and
things like that but they're never going
to rise up
and so those are lessons that i take and
without
outing anybody and the artist and the
record label the commissioner
and i teach people on my account to do
better
you know so a new person should not have
done it for free
for well i mean that artist a new person
would not get it
uh okay you know first of all yeah okay
i have a
generally a three rule the the free
shoot should always come
from you never if if i want you to
photograph
me for free it's gonna benefit me the
most
if it's my idea first if it's your idea
and you're doing a test shoot and you're
building your book
that's okay because the initial gain is
for you
and then three maybe four
call it a day if you can't convince
people and and so
don't do a newborn shoot then a wedding
then
automotive then a landscape that's not
being smart about it
so if you're going to do if you're going
to start a wedding photography business
then do three or four engagement shoots
or weddings
and if you can't sell people on those
three or four weddings
then there's another problem maybe you
have to develop your photo skills you
know or editing or
curation and stuff like that
so you lost a job big job still hurts
was this when you decided you wanted was
this one of the things was during
that was during that so many things they
would say certain things
that was just not kind and
generalize a certain population and
stuff and
um and i thought gosh i see no problem
with that so they would say i'm hard to
market because
blah blah blah and and i'm like so then
go and market me to
that market seems like i've got it
cornered
you know do your job and so um that's
why i never did well with because i knew
too much because i had to negotiate my
own contracts and everything
and how even have fake emails initially
the beginning of my career
like a fake manager that i'm like okay
log into this one now and log into this
one right
so but i've negotiated and i've done it
and i budgeted and i built
a a crew and i've done everything
so it was yeah so that what you said the
album cover for
extra for instagram exchanges was during
that time it was getting a postcard
saying
maybe it's because you're too heavy and
you need to lose some weight
and that was after i rejected their idea
of i photograph
too much of a certain population i was
in a coffee shop the other day and i
heard a man giving a woman business
advice i guess he was like hired
and he said look business is not warm
and fuzzy you need to know what you're
getting into this is this not
is like you know things could get really
cutthroat you know she was a sweet woman
he was like counseling her or whatever
and is that the same advice you would
made me tell people
that even though they're very skilled
with the camera and they have a great
eye
that they need to know that part
or is that going to put people off i
don't think that
i i think that birds of a feather flock
together
and initially if you surround yours
so yes and no to your answer first of
all
do your best to surround yourself with
good people
good people will refer you good people
good people will refer you crew members
that are good people
bad people hang out with bad people not
something i've learned
and so um i'm very very cautious of who
i give my time to and my attention to
but i would tell them
to be tough and if it's cut throat
if it's cut throat understand that it's
not personal
but do what you can to make cutthroat
like five percent of your business
and go in with statements and
certain things in your back pocket so i
tell
like these new photographers it's okay
to say
let me think about it let me get back to
you it's okay
because really cutthroat people really
dishonest people
they know how to corner a new person and
get your commit
and you haven't been jaded yet so you're
gonna really keep your word
so i tell them remove yourself out of
the situation
take a deep breath and go with what
feels right or like
feel it out ask people um
and go there so it doesn't have to get
cut throat you just
pull out of that room and if they're
very cutthroat
they usually have it out for you and if
i can add one more thing to that
if a person tells you they are honest
get the hell out of the room
immediately if they have to tell you
they're honest
they are the least thing from honest
because they they
they sense that you see their true
character
and so now they're like oh no let me
sell them
that i don't screw people over that i'm
honest no i need to see that in your
behavior
so that's the biggest thing i tell
people walk away
what if they say they do things on a
handshake they they
that's nice but no
i'll break a contract before i break a
handshake but it has
sometimes the best people i cut you off
and i apologize but
the the best people um
they're so spread thin that they forget
they forget what the deal was on a
handshake
so they don't they don't necessarily
intend to ruin you
they just forgot and they confuse you
with somebody else so when
even if it's a very simple deal memo if
somebody's like i go on a handshake
then simplify the contract and just do a
simple deal memo
i will do this this this this you will
do this this this
cover the five w's who what when where
and why cover it
then both sign and it's done and i
there's so many times i'm like hey
um we said this
you're saying this is this a
misunderstanding or should we
find a compromise it just helps because
you can't deny what's written you know
and people are very cool generally
you